auau travail et à l'école,
lala Santé publique du Québec
nene s'en cache pas.s...
DrDr LUC BOILEAU, directeur
nanational Santé publique, Québc
- - On le sait, le virus nous a
susurpris plusieurs fois.
- - Des variants du virus
dede la COVID-19 pourraient
àà nouveau perturber
lala vie des Québécois.
C Cela dit, avec le temps,
dedes chercheurs chez Moderna
onont mis au point une version
amaméliorée de leur vaccin,
ququi cible spécifiquement
lele variant Omicron, le variant
lele plus répandu d'Europe.
L Les autorités britanniques
l'l'ont approuvé aujourd'hui
susur leur territoire.
EtEt des pourparlers ont déjà lu
dedepuis le 30 juin entre Modera
etet Santé Canada,
afafin que le vaccin
fafasse son entrée ici au papay.
D Dans une déclaration écrite,
lala pharmaceutique américaine
afaffirme que :
- - S'il est approuvé par
leles instances officielles,
ououi, absolument, je l'aurais
prpris aujourd'hui.
- - Je pense qu'il faudrait
quque je lise beaucoup d'articl,
d'd'abord, sur ça, parce que
jeje ne veux pas me piquer
sisi je ne sais pas ce qu'on
meme met dans le corps.
- - Bien, si ça permet de nous
prprotéger, puis de nous garder
enen santé, moi puis ma famille,
c'c'est sûr.
- - Fait important à souligner :
lele premier vaccin de Moderna
cocontinue d'offrir une protectn
cocontre les formes sévères
dede la maladie.
L La version 2.0 du vaccin
dodonnerait donc une couverture
imimmunitaire plus ciblée,
seselon lele Dr Karl Weiss.
DrDr KARL WEISS, microbiologist,
àà l'Hôpital général juif, MTL
- - Ces vaccins, il faut les vo,
fifinalement, comme une marque
d'd'automobile avec un modèle
amamélioré d'année en année.
DoDonc, avec les années, on gage
enen expérience, on est capable
d'd'avoir des s vaccins qui sont
plplus polyvalents et qui vont
dodonner une couverture
imimmunitaire peut-être
plplus ciblée, je vous dirais,
àà long terme.
- - Alors qu'on parle de plus
enen plus d'une huitième vague
àà l'automne, le premier ministe
FrFrançois Legault donnera
unune conférence de presse mard,
popour inciter les Québécois
àà recevoir leur dose de rappel.
I Ici, Gabrielle Proulx,
R Radio-Canada, Montréa